in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions James
and Lisa are with us hey guys how are
you how are you better than I deserve
welcome welcome good to have you where
are you guys from we're from Janesville
Wisconsin it's about 45 minutes south of
Madison oh very cool I'll see the
Brewers t-shirts right yes essentially
what we're doing okay good plan and so
your kids are with you how old are they
and one of their names this is Noah he
just turned 11 three days ago mm-hmm and
Leah who's eight all right very fun well
nice road trip from Madison to Nashville
yeah it's a bit of a haul and out here
to do your debt-free scream I assume yes
sir cool how much have you paid off we
paid off seventeen thousand one hundred
and twenty-four dollars very good and
how long did that take you just under 17
months very cool and your household
income during that time started off
about 45 thousand a year mm-hmm and then
worked up to about 55 thousand a year
good for you good for you what do you
guys do for a living I manage a
restaurant
oh very cool good for you guys so what
kind of debt was the 17,000 we had a
little bit of credit card debt and then
most of it was on the car okay all right
so you're kind of normal yep just
bopping along and what happened 17
months ago that made you get on this
journey to get out of debt well part of
the brewery gear that we're wearing is
because we're obviously big Brewer fans
to where I always had it on in the car
listen to the Brewers listen the packers
and we'd go to pick the kids up from
school and it would just be on and after
a while in the afternoon I heard this
this guy ranting and raving about using
credit cards and and getting out of debt
and yelling at people and stuff and it
just kind of made me listen a little bit
more and realize that we were one of
those people and that we needed to clean
some stuff up okay and so Lisa he comes
home and sports radio has been
transformed somehow into a crazy man
talking about money and says we need to
get some his debt cleaned up what did
you say um for the most part I was
pretty much on board we've always
communicated well about finding
and so I was like well let's do it we
got to change our family tree all right
good very cool so what was the first
thing you did was the first step you
took first step we took just started
listening more I listened to the podcast
all the time on iHeartRadio I'd be like
no walk around with headphones that work
listen to it all day and then you know
we both you know looked up the baby
steps online to see what those were
about learned from that mm-hmm and then
that that first Christmas we just said
that our gift to each other was just
gonna be a total money makeover oh wow
we went online about that aisle both
read it welcome and then it just went on
from there and then just follow the baby
steps oh yeah it was it was really the
first time where we had a plan you know
we just kind of we're sitting idly by
and going through the motions and
thought we were doing okay I'm the nerd
I had the spreadsheet budget that we use
but it was it was the same every month
and and everything extra was always oh
this is what we can just blow on
whatever we want yeah I mean that just
got us into trouble more than anything
well you make good progress thousand
bucks a month on 45k that's pretty
strong I mean you were really watching
what you're doing to pull that off that
that's excellent
so what did you cut back on to make this
family the hardest one at first was
probably cable I cut the cable out so
it's harder to watch the Brewers and the
Packers and stuff I don't but after a
while we learned not we didn't even miss
it and now that we're debt-free we don't
even plan on getting it back oh really
no um that was one of the hardest things
at first but after a while didn't really
feel necessary anymore
okay very cool well congratulations you
guys all right so what what are the keys
what are the secrets to getting out of
that when people ask you how you did
this what he told the secrets are well I
think the budget and communication was
just huge we always did it every other
week had a budget meeting mm-hmm talked
about what were these next two weeks
gonna look like and we would you know
have our budget for the month but we
would you know reallocate if we needed
to and readjust things and one of the
things for us was when we first started
to save our thousand dollar starter
emergency fund we had a lot of issues
with a car breaking and stuff like that
and that was almost disheartening
because we couldn't make
progress towards a thousand people so
then in our budget we started including
a hundred bucks every paycheck for car
maintenance mm-hmm and and had like
another little mini car emergency fund
yeah you know came in handy numerous
times and so kept you from losing feel
like you were losing pace right yeah
look in progress it was a lot easier
when it was just a little bit every time
it's where you didn't even think about
it and then when you needed it you had
plenty - there it was a little car
savings account yeah very good good plan
well that's the kind of how the repair
account works if you're using the
envelope system you'll just build up the
money in there until you need the
repairs it is it's like a miniature
savings account well very good you guys
excellent excellent job so the kids been
involved yep yep we started we read
smart money smart kids you know we
worked out our chore charts at home and
you know put the kids to work and help
them learn money and and they've been
doing really good at saving their money
too in order to you know shoot for a
goal that they have as well
they look like hard workers and they are
so the big question is have they been
practicing their debt-free scream yes we
have all the way from Madison Wisconsin
oh okay good deal because you know the
kids kind of get rated on whether they
can do the screamer or not around here I
mean the youtubers watch and everybody's
checking them out so you got it you know
no Aaliyah you got to bring it I mean
you got to bring it it's like a Brewers
game or even better a Packers game you
know so there you go a lot of cheering
going on these days so good job you guys
congratulations we're gonna give you a
copy of Chris Hogan's book retire
inspired signed by him which will take
you on to the next level number one
best-selling book and it'll show you how
to go do the next chapter in your story
and because you guys have definitely
killed it I'm so proud of you thank you
you're absolute heroes way to go you
changed your family tree you got to feel
great being in control that's the best
feeling I love it alright it's James and
Lisa Noah and Liam Madison Wisconsin
$17,000 paid off in 17 months making
forty five now making fifty five count
it down let's hear a debt free scream
three two one
good job they did a good job way to go
you guys
very well done that's how you do it
right there man that's perfect
very very cool hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000 in
economy